here's canadian dictator justin trudeau
trying to scare the hell out of
everybody today's a difficult day
the judgment coming out of the united
states is an attack
on women's freedom and quite frankly
it's an attack on everyone's
freedoms and rights
let me be really really clear in canada
we will always
defend women's rights to choose
and continue to work to expand
access to the full range of reproductive
health and services across the country
all right so he's a deeply inauthentic
snake person um interestingly canada
allows for abortion for any reason up
until the moment of birth is that
correct so eight months in eight months
in that's what canada does and canada i
guess are the good guys in this case a
lot of dead
late-term babies
uh and that makes you a good guy somehow
right and this is an attack on women's
freedom suddenly all these people know
what women are which is also rather
extraordinary
now interestingly a couple years ago
about 10 years ago justin trudeau wasn't
that into abortion
now i'm getting guff from the other side
because i said i don't like abortion
does anyone who's pro-choice as i am
really like abortion now that was when
justin trudeau was actually
sort of sane when because he wasn't
always a complete
left maniac but what happens is you give
these guys an inch and they take a mile
this is what has so consistently
happened with almost everyone on the
left virtually every lefty they've got
no emergency brake the car is going
towards the cliff they know it's going
towards the cliff and there's just no
emergency brake instead they just put
their the pedal to the metal that's
consistently
why they
end up in these crazy positions where 10
years ago he was saying i don't like
abortion and now it's horrific that in
the united states they will let states
choose about abortion it's rather
extraordinary related to my own
political evolution i guess i guess
somewhere along the way i decided that
having an emergency break was important
and i think that's why i've evolved out
of this
complete leftist lunacy i mean that that
really is where we're at